a good tuesday evening to you thank you
for joining us on 8 news now at 5 i'm
brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez all across the
country millions of americans are
missing appointments for their second
vaccine dose
according to the cdc more than 5 million
skipped their second
pfizer or modernity doses as of early
april a critical component in protecting
people
eight news now reporter victoria saha
joins us now live with why you should
not miss it victoria
the southern nevada health district is
doing everything they can to make it as
easy as possible for you to get
vaccinated
including hosting many pop-up vaccine
clinics like the one here at the
hollywood recreation center on the east
side of the valley
but no matter where you go for your
first dose dose it's
crucial to finish the vaccination
process and get your second dose
the southern nevada health district says
currently 99
000 individuals in clark county are
eligible to get their second dose
but have not gotten it dr mack j khan at
the
current school of medicine says if you
think that you are somewhat protected
with just the first dose you may want to
think again
so the first dose of the vaccine primes
the immune system
or gets it ready for the infection the
second dose or the booster
magnifies that immune response to really
provide
much more protection against a viral
infection
not completing your full vaccination
series also diminishes the state's
efforts to slow the virus
if you are a few weeks behind from your
second dose it's not too late to
schedule your second dose
but you want to do it sooner rather than
later and this location right behind me
at the hollywood recreation center
is taking appointments until 8 pm
tonight and then again tomorrow
4pm until 8 pm reporting live victoria
saha
8 news now